hello everyone and welcome to another
spectacular attacking game uh from the
super bad rapid tournament it's levon
arun versus vishwanathan anand and
anan's been having an uh spectacular
tournament he's just been crushing
everyone and uh well i don't want to
spoil too much but if you've seen anan's
immortal game which was played against
none other than levon arunian in the
tata still 2013 edition uh also with the
black pieces then
you probably know what's in store for
you this game so let's dive straight
into it there is a lot to enjoy you guys
i've received the hundreds of requests
after this game was played and it's only
uh been a few maybe maybe an hour since
it was played so let's check it out it's
really a beauty uh levon has the white
pieces and he opens with e4 and if there
if by any chance you still haven't seen
anan's immortal game uh the first link
in the description below you do not want
to miss that one so here we have e5
bishop to c4 everyone wants the surprise
on with the bishop opening knight to f6
we have d3 and bishop to c5 we have
knight to f3
and the d6 so a perfectly symmetrical
position castles by both players keeping
the symmetry and now c3 uh here anan
goes bishop back to b6 this bishop can
very easily be attacked with b4 d4
and then you might um you know just uh
get give white free moves to harass your
bishop so so you just move it to b6
knight b to d2 and now c6 bion and at
some point the bishop can be shifted to
c7 or you can use this to strike in the
center with the d5
we have bishop to b3 and now rook to e8
and here
the position is a known one in 1999 in
dortmund uh michael adams uh played this
against vladimir kramik and they uh
they drew their game but in that game
bishop the c2 was played here we have
rook to e1 by levon and it is now as of
move nine that we have a completely new
game i saw anand continues development
bishop to e6 challenges the bishop on b3
and now levon just brings it back bishop
to c2 we have knight beat to d7 and
finally we have a strike in the center
with d4 uh bishop to g4 uh island was
waiting for levon to push d4 to weaken
the e4 pawn so now when the bishop is
challenged you're going to move it to h5
and if g4 then bishop the g6 will put
more pressure on the e4 pawn which isn't
all that impressive
while the pawn on d3 is still defending
the e4 pawn so here h3 bishop h5 g4
bishop to g6 and now d captures an e5 we
have knight captures by anand and
knight captures and rook captures and
this is where the uh game really becomes
interesting uh it's only move 15 but it
seems uh levon uh evaluates the position
uh incorrectly uh he likes that the
bishop and the rook are in in the grasp
of the knights fork so uh the bishop
here a beautiful piece the rook a
a stronger piece than the bishop so you
might use the fork to just get rid of
the bishop because this bishop is a
monster and it makes sense to attack it
but there's a problem after knight to c4
uh anand quickly played knight captures
an e4 and there's your problem uh you
don't really have a you don't really
have a moment to capture the rook
because now okay uh olive one says uh
anand says you can capture my rook but
if you do this knight captures on f2 and
that's it white can resign
there are also sorts of nasty
discoveries being threatened and you
can't really avoid this as your queen is
hanging too so once you move the queen
then we just combine everything bishop
captures on c2 the knight is hanging uh
i mean this is just a disgusting
disgusting position so instead after
knight captures an e4 uh
well levon says all right you got
something there i'm just going to
eliminate the bishop on b6 instead and
now you've got nothing except that's not
true anand is completely winning here so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for lavon uh for
for anand while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
bishop was never really captured or
rather it was but the queen will take
its place and then the position is
pretty much the same only only uh only
even even better for anand uh here
knight captures nf2 congratulations to
everyone who founded this uh you are a
true creator of immortal rapid games uh
and now how do you counter this the
queen is hanging uh not much to be done
uh about this if the king captures the
knight then this queen to age for check
and it's game over uh the rook anyone
will hang if the king doesn't defend it
so king f1 has to be played and now this
crushing bishop captures on c2 we can
even do this one in slow motion because
it's just so powerful now the queen is
attacked the queen has no squares if you
if you move the queen from the defense
of the rook then this falls away to
check this is just uh uh hard to even
look at so instead after knight captures
an f2 we have queen to d2 levon plays
the absolute strongest move recommended
by the engine but even this is not
enough to save him because now the queen
becomes the bishop queen captures on b6
and again you have this problem there's
no way to uh there's no way to deal with
this uh it seems like you can capture
the knight but you really can't if queen
captures an f2 uh rook captures anyone
with check and the queen of course is
pinned you cannot capture this and once
you move the king uh pretty much
anything is winning here one of the
nicer moves is king the g2 and then just
rook eight to e8 you don't even care
about the white trading queens here uh
because after captures and captures the
position is just unplayable for white
the other rook is coming to e2 and
that's it even if you trade the bishops
here bishop captures h captures there's
no way to
free up your position or or to develop
it's uh just completely lost uh another
thing after queen captures on b6 you
could play king to g2 you just unpin and
you say all right do you have anything
here but still after knight to e4
completely completely unplayable the
queen is attacked you can't really just
go anywhere because queen to f2 is
coming
so let's say queen e3 you offer a queen
trade we play knight c5 now just attack
the queen threaten uh to trade rooks and
after queen f2 we can trade here
captures captures and now just bishop
captures on c2 we pick up a piece of
course uh this is completely unplayable
uh your white is on material and not
only that the king is completely the the
king said is completely busted uh you
cannot play this
so and it's still only move 18. so levon
goes for the third try which is also uh
one of the engine's top recommendations
but even this will not save him because
now anand just goes knight the g4 check
opens up a discovery this will uh
capture the rook back king the g2 knight
captures an e5 and now uh okay you
you're not down uh
too much material you are only down two
pawns but look at your king so here uh
levon traits uh trades a pair of bishops
characters captures and now even wins
the pawn but now queen to b5 defending
the knight also threatening queen to e2
so queen to d1 preventing the queen's
infiltration and now knight to d3 and
again the problem is there is no good uh
good move here for white v3 was played
but not just queen to d5 check and he
was in this position on move 24 uh that
lavon arnhem resigned the game and
another brilliant brilliant victory by
vishwanathan and against the the same
opponent nine years later uh again with
the black pieces simply simply
incredible uh like uh you really you if
you if you happen to do check out uh
anand's immortal game uh
and then you will appreciate this one
even even more i believe but uh i mean
such a such a brutal brutal display of
power and uh anand is uh for the moment
uh i believe unbeatable uh or unbeaten
but also unbeatable in this tournament
uh let me just
check if i have this to show you guys
just a second uh
yeah i do have it let me just load that
up
just a second there we go
uh yeah these are uh these are uh onions
games be
up until this point so you can see that
he defeated whiter shack he defeated
wesley so he defeated korowa and
defeated kiroshvchenko and now defeated
leblanc arunan so five wins in a row i
know for a fact that while i was
recording uh he got a draw against duda
so he still has a governor let's go
caruana and rapport uh so uh
uh
for three of those players uh three of
those four players are candidates so
it's not gonna be easy for ireland but
as you've seen uh doesn't seem to be all
that uh all that difficult for him uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
another brilliancy by ananda with the
black pieces thank you for suggesting
this one it's uh really a spectacular
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank david kimura francis air
adam simmons robert kiefer and the mark
manor for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and continuing uh to cover
everything that's happening in the chess
world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out anand's immortal if you
still haven't first link in the
description see you soon